the freedom convoy of canadian truckers
protesting vaccine mandates is not
backing down and now there are reports
that the department of homeland security
is warning that an american trucker
convoy could start this weekend at the
super bowl our very own chad program is
reporting that the concern is now
growing in washington among lawmakers
about a coordinated trucker convoy going
to d.c and as support for the freedom
convoy grows liberals well they're
losing their minds one cnn fake news
commentator tweeted today
slashed their tires
isn't that a threat are those kind of
threats legal our own sarah carter is
live again in ottawa with with the
freedom convoy uh sarah a lot of support
from our viewers last night uh for all
those people there please send our best
oh sean hannity sends his best a lot of
support from the viewers sean i got to
tell you i spent the day with a lot of
the families a lot of the truckers in
the convoy just outside of ottawa as
they prepared to convoy from where they
were at a small town just outside here
towards the city and i've had the
opportunity to spend time with all of
you here in the city and i've been able
to see what's been happening you know a
lot of the truckers here and their
families are concerned about the
government they're concerned about the
police taking their private private
property without any reason they've told
me about their concerns for their own
children but they say they are not going
to move they are going to continue to
make their stand
despite what prime minister justin
trudeau has said and i want you to take
a listen to what they had to say today
what drove you to join the convoy i mean
when was it that you said okay this is
it i'm coming i'm joining the convoy i'm
joining chris and the rest of you i've
been kind of praying for something to
happen for a couple years already i mean
i don't know if i'm supposed to say this
but i mean this country's been under the
grasp of a tyrant since he got in so
right so i mean
i do want to say though i do have to i
do have to thank the man though
because of the unity he's brought canada
i mean quebec everybody's together now
so you know what thank you trudeau
you know they come at us with the jerry
cans downtown you're not allowed to
touch a jerry can you could be arrested
with it we've turned that into a mockery
there's people downtown running around
with empty jerry cans tied around their
necks with police chasing them all over
the place just for the fear enjoyment of
of trying to trip this up so well that's
what's interesting those gas cans i was
there yesterday when the police went in
and took a whole load of gas cans and
nothing was happening i mean nobody had
done anything to provoke that uh so you
kind of turned that into almost a big
joke
did you ever think the truckers that
y'all would be like the on the front
lines of soldiers for liberty and
freedom no this is this is like a dream
every day is an adventure
a mind game adventure and it's fun
[Music]
sean i have matt mckenzie with me here
he's been with the convoy since the very
beginning he's been here in ottawa his
truck is parked right in front of
parliament and uh matt i want to ask you
a question
for the majority of people here have
been warm welcoming
really really standing up for what they
believe is freedom how do you think the
last two weeks have reflected on what's
happened in the united states now with
the convoy starting up there
i think it's wonderful to see and
i think it took strong canadians to get
this movement moving and i think it's
spread worldwide it's not just the
united states we love our brothers and
sisters who've come up here to give
their support to us as well but this is
a worldwide movement i don't think it
can be stopped
what about the prime minister how do you
feel about prime minister trudeau
uh where do i start that's i don't think
we have enough time um
i think that uh
it's a little bit frustrating when you
hear some of the rhetoric that's being
spread around and the rumors that uh
have have been going around about us and
his opinion
sean has a question right yeah
go ahead sarah what i want to ask i want
you to ask the whole crowd i want what
what they think of the gutless spineless
cowardly prime minister trudeau
i want to know how they feel about him
i'm going to try to remember that
okay sean wants to know from the crowd
how you feel about the gutless spineless
cowardly prime minister trudeau
[Music]
did i do it right
i think you got it i think you get the
message sean but i but do they know the
extent
here's the question i have do they know
the extent to which the american people
are supporting them are they surprised
an american convoy is starting are they
surprised one in new zealand is starting
are they surprised that they're popping
up all over europe
do you sean wants to know again do you
understand that because this started
here do you understand the extent that
this has reflected on america that an
american convoy is starting that uh that
the new people in new zealand are rising
up that people in australia
[Applause]
sean
sean i gotta tell you there is a nine
the bravest question of all time
ask them if they care at all bravest
ask them if they care at all that i'm a
rangers and an islanders fan
do you care at all that he's a rangers
and an islanders fan
[Music]
i i think i think you've got a lot of
support here and a lot of love sean even
i do but you know what's bad but tell
them i can't stand their cowardly prime
minister so i stand with them on the
important issues
sean seeing that you're a rangers fan
why don't you see if you can get ron
mclean
kelly rudy
wayne gretzky cindy crosby
all these guys that we've supported all
our lives to support us we need the nhl
we need the nhl
i agree that's when i'm here
i played hockey my whole life so
where are the boys
[Music]
i gotta tell you sean i could barely
hear you now
all right sarah great job as always
send our solidarity love and uh well
uh support for all of the brave people
that are there don't give up don't let
people portray you as something you're
not and don't let anybody get out of
control keep it peaceful and you'll win
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else